- [Reporter] In this
1989 Revlon commercial,
the cosmetics company asked
a question to its customers.
- [Announcer] What makes
a woman unforgettable?
- A little luck and
the right shade of red.
- [Reporter] The answer to
that question was, of course,
Revlon cosmetics.
For much of the 20th century,
Revlon products were a
mainstay in the makeup aisle,
once capturing 1/5 of all
department store cosmetic sales
in the United States.
But in the 21st century,
Revlon has found itself
battling declining market share
and increasingly crowded shelf space.
Now, with the company
recently averting a bankruptcy filing,
questions remain if the
once unforgettable brand
is on its way to being forgotten.
(soft tense music)
- You know, when you look
wonderful, you feel wonderful.
And the secret can be the makeup you use.
- [Reporter] Revlon
helped usher in the era
of color cosmetics in the
first half of the 20th century.
The company was founded
in 1932 by Charles Revson
along with his brother, Joseph,
and chemist Charles Lachman.
It started by selling nail polish
but quickly moved into lipsticks.
Sales of cosmetics surged
between 1941 and 1946.
Revlon positioned itself
to meet this demand,
claiming its products were
seen on the fingertips
and lips of the nation's smartest women.
- Revlon is a brand that,
for decades, really,
for a generation was the
biggest, most ubiquitous,
sought after, kind of cutting edge brands
and it was what you thought of
when you thought of mass market,
yet very desirable makeup.
- [Reporter] The
cornerstones of Revlon's rise
were mass production and mass marketing.
It spent heavily on advertising,
sponsoring popular TV programs
and pinning exclusive deals
with beauty shop suppliers.
- [Announcer] Revlon, the
greatest name in cosmetics,
presents the 1, 2, 4, 8, 16, 32, 64,
yes, "The $64,000 Question."
- [Reporter] Charles Revson is said
to have described Revlon's
strategy like this:
"In the factory, we make cosmetics.
In the store, we sell hope."
Selling hope helped
bolster the company sales,
and in the 1960s and
'70s, Revlon branched out,
expanding into
pharmaceuticals and apparel.
In 1975, Charles Revson died
and European businessman
Michel Bergerac took the helm.
A year later, Revlon sales
reached nearly $1 billion,
although it was still second
in sales behind Avon products
with its door-to-door distribution.
The cosmetics conglomerate
kept pace with changing trends
as more women entered the workforce,
marketing its products to
on-the-go, career-driven women.
- [Announcer] Now the world
belongs to Charlie by Revlon.
- [Reporter] But by the early
1980s, sales had flattened,
and in a decade marked
by hostile takeovers,
one of the top corporate raiders
had Revlon in his sights.
Businessman Ron Perelman
initiated a hostile takeover
of Revlon in 1985.
The takeover bid dominated headlines,
detailing the struggle
between Perelman and Bergerac
for control of the company.
- He said to me, very proudly,
that he hunted lions and tigers
so I was not a threat to him.
- [Reporter] Ultimately,
Perelman prevailed,
becoming chairman of Revlon's board
and controlling shareholder.
Perelman enlisted famed fashion
photographer Richard Avedon
to shoot the unforgettable ad campaign,
bringing top supermodels
like Christy Turlington
and Cindy Crawford to
be the faces of Revlon.
At first blush, Revlon appeared poised
to end the century on a high note.
However, its finances were
telling a different story.
Perelman had used junk bonds
to finance the takeover.
It was assumed he would sell
Revlon's non-beauty businesses
to pay down this debt.
Instead, he turned his
focus to a failed bid
to take over Gillette
and this came at a time
when competition was heating up.
Proctor & Gamble acquired
several makeup brands,
snatching up 1/3 of the
cosmetics market by 1990,
compared to Revlon's
share of just over 20%.
At the same time, Revlon
was stretched thin.
It was carrying nine upscale product lines
with nearly 3,000 individual products.
But women were wearing
less and less makeup
as they moved away from the
bright colors of the '80s
to more muted, natural looks.
The company launched
its hit Colorstay
non-transferable lipstick in 1995
and went public in 1996.
However, much of Revlon's pre-tax profits
were going to serve as
its $1.3 billion of debt.
- Late in the century,
it turned into a company
that was just a little
bit behind the trends.
You know, things started,
fashion started shifting
away from these bright colors
and Revlon didn't adapt to that change.
It caught on somewhat late
to the shift toward skincare
and skin health and was
still really selling
kind of these, you know,
these color cosmetics
that were changing.
- [Reporter] By 2003,
Revlon had experienced
16 straight quarters of losses,
and by 2007, its share of the
cosmetics market had fallen
to 11% in mass market retailers.
Despite this, Perelman continued
to keep the company afloat
with injections of cash in
a revolving door of CEOs
- Mr. Perelman, he said, and
this was more than a decade ago
in an interview with "The
Wall Street Journal,"
he said, "For good or bad,
I'm defined by Revlon."
He led rescues.
He just bailed the company
out over and over again
as it continued to struggle.
- [Reporter] Revlon tried to
recapture part of the market
with high profile
acquisitions of Colomer Group
and Elizabeth Arden.
But by 2017, its market share
had dwindled to around 6%.
By then, Revlon was not only
facing stiff competition
from the likes of Proctor
& Gamble and L'Oreal,
but from startups with serious star power.
Celebrity-backed makeup lines
like Kylie Jenner's Kylie cosmetics
had burst onto the scene.
- You know, a company,
whether it's Revlon,
whether it's CoverGirl,
these are companies
that have massive
advertising budgets, models,
TV commercials, and with
the rise of social media,
we're seeing brands that
are driven by influencers,
by Kylie Jenner, who
has a cosmetics company
that has $200 million in annual sales
even though there's only
less than a dozen people
who work at her company.
And she doesn't spend money on advertising
because she just has so
many Instagram followers.
- [Reporter] In 2018,
Perelman provided Revlon
with a financial lifeline and
installed his daughter, Debra,
as CEO, the company's first
female chief executive.
Through much of 2020, widespread closures
and bankruptcies among
retailers, salons, and spas
crimped sales of beauty products.
- The main thing is that
our lips are covered
when we wear masks so lipstick
sales have have fallen off.
There used to be a term in the industry
called the lipstick index and
how much women were spending
on makeup kind of as a
proxy for the economy,
and he said, "Well you can't really use
the lipstick index anymore
because nobody can see our lips."
- [Reporter] The dip couldn't have come
at a worst time for Revlon.
With a $343 million bond payment looming,
Revlon refinanced its
debt to avoid bankruptcy.
- If you look at kind
of some of the analysts
and some of the industry experts,
they question whether
this deal to save Revlon
has just kicked the can down the road.
Certainly, old brands,
brands that are struggling
have revived themselves before.
I would say Revlon has a tougher road
and it's an entire company, not a brand.
But it's hard to say where
they're gonna end up.
- [Reporter] Where Revlon ends up
will depend on how it adapts
to the modern beauty landscape
and if it can inject a little color
into an otherwise bleak outlook.